the aftermath of a tragedy one that's
still causing heartache a year on last
June 2000 migrants stormed a high fence
separating Morocco from the small
Spanish territory of Malia this video
released by the Moroccan Association of
Human Rights appears to show Moroccan
officers beating survivors
and here they walk around as people lie
Motionless
suddenly one person gasps
Morocco's government said some of the
Dead fell from the border fence While
others suffocated as people panicked and
started a stampede it put the death toll
at least 23. Amnesty International says
the figure was at least 37 with at least
76 missing in 76
disappears in the days after the people
that were sent to to the desert injuries
was put in buses to the desert and lived
there so we are talking about the very
the most serious massacre in the border
between Morocco and Spain in 25 years
an investigation by Spain's public
prosecutor found no evidence of criminal
wrongdoing Spanish opposition parties
have demanded the interior Minister
resign but the government says any
deaths happened outside Spanish
territory calling the actions of its
Security Forces irreproachable Morocco's
declined to comment but it has
reportedly jailed dozens of people
involved in storming the Border in a
statement the head of amnesty says Spain
and Morocco are hiding the truth one
year on from the Carnage at Malia
Spanish and Moroccan authorities not
only continue to deny any responsibility
but are preventing attempts to find the
truth bodies are still lying in a morgue
and engraves and efforts to identify the
dead and inform their relatives have
been blocked barriers to truth and
Justice are also a reflection of the
continuing harmful treatment based on
race and migration status
such a huge loss of life in a single
incident involving migrants on land is
rare sadly the same can't be said for
sea crossings from the North African
Coastline Nadine barber Al Jazeera